diese brückeneinweihung fällt ins Wasser
[Applaus]
genau in dem Moment in dem diese
offiziellen ein Band durchschneiden um
eine neue Brücke einzuweihen gibt diese
nach und bricht in sich zusammen
Glück im Unglück die Brücke ist nicht
besonders groß und der Fluss den sie
überspannt ist er ein Flüsschen weshalb
die Rettungsaktion auch unfreiwillig
komisch wirkt verletzt wird hier nur das
Ego der Brückenbauer sonst niemand dafür
wird in den sozialen Medien umso mehr
gelacht vor allem über den Soldaten mit
Sonnenbrille und Sektflasche in der Hand
und über die Tatsache das offenbar nur
das Band die Brücke zusammengehalten
hatte
[Musik]